JOINING HUSBAND BROTHERS.PINBAL
OVER AND RUZICKA DIVES AND POKES
IT OUT TO CENTER ICE.
FLAMES TAKE CONTROL AND HEAD UP
CORNER, PUT IT IN FRONT AND
CHIPPED WIDE OF THE GOAL BEHIND
LINE.
>> Rick: ZADINA'S SHOT BLOCKED
BY STONE.
HAYES
>> Greg: TOUGH PLAY FOR SHOULDEF
GREISS.
BACK TO THE COCO ALONE HIS
OFFENSIVE OUTPUT, 29
BACK TO THE LINE.
STECHER IS THERE.
THROWS IT AHEAD, AND WITKOWSKI
REGROUPS AND GOES BACK TO
THE BLUE LINE.
THAT BACKS RIGHT UP TAKE TOO
KINDLY TO
>> Rick: RIGHT OVER THE PADAD D.
THERE'S MARKSTROM AGAIN BEHIND
THE NET AK OUT, HE DUMPS THE
PUCK IN OFF THE
IT BEHIND HIS NET.
OESTERLE THERE
DETROIT CREATES ANOTHER CHANCE
FOR THE CALGARY FLAME HIS STICK.
AND GREISS WAS SWIMMING A LITTLE
FUTURE ENDEAVORS.
I KNOW HE WANTS TO HELP YOUNGNS
IN THIS GAME LIKE THIS THAT THEY
HAVE A STRUCTURE PAIRING HELPS
AS WELL WITH HANIFIN AND  OF
WATCHING TANEV.
SETTLE IT DOWN.
AN
GOALTENDER, YOUR PLAY READS ARE
GOOD AND LINE.
FED BACK AROUND BY RAYMOND.
PENALTY WINDING DOWN.
LARKIN MAKES A PASS, INTERCEPTE.
E
IT'S JUST THE WAY THIS GAME HAS
BEARD ACKNOWLEDGED BY Greg: HE
OPEN UP THE SHORT SIDE.
>> G.
HE FINDS IT THIS TIME.
HE FIND TOFFOLI IN AN IDENTICAL
PLAY, REALLY, BUT THISLEMAN, OV
STONE.
PASS TO TANEV, TAKES
>> Rick: THERE IT CONTEST
THI
POINT.
I'VE BEEN WRONG ON THESE MANY
TIMES GOING TO
THE NET. TO THE